we're being overrun no sector is  everywhere  all of them as long as I can what are  you doing here it's happening again  Paris was just the beginning this is a  global innovation so look up there  that's the command ship and we know what  we have to do  you're with me we're getting aboard that  ship I knew he would return one day he  has been too long  faster  I can't do this  you've made your choice nobody was stop  us  trouble is cropping up all over the  world it's not just and all sector  a lot of lives are riding on what we do  next will you have to fight one city at  a time  [Music]  let's read them Perdita  watching your back  that's teamwork  a new trick  [Music]  strike  Warren are worthless it  direction I am tulip listen please  [Music]  so Joan herre  you  you